(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) A gente viu que é possível comprar um
imóvel utilizando um financiamento em leilão exclujiticial.
E aí existem duas possibilidades de você recorrer
a esse financiamento em um leilão exclujiticial.
Dois pontos que você pode usar a seu
favor.
O primeiro ponto é você diminuir o capital
necessário para ingressar nos leilões.
Pode ser que você não tenha o capital
necessário para arrematar um imóvel à vista.
Ou não tenha o capital necessário para arrematar
melhores imóveis à vista.
E aí você poderia recorrer a um financiamento
em um leilão exclujiticial.
E diminuir o capital necessário para ingressar no
mercado dos leilões.
Quando você faz a opção por arrematar com
um financiamento em leilão exclujiticial, você vai ter
que pagar à vista o valor da entrada,
a comissão do leiloeiro, o ITBI, o registro.
E aí você vai ter os custos de
manutenção daquele imóvel, que é condomínio IPT-1
mensal.
E você vai ter que pagar as parcelas
daquele financiamento até a venda do imóvel.
Mas isso aí é indiscutível que vai ser
um capital muito menor do que se você
comprasse aquele imóvel à vista.
E existe um outro ponto também em que
pode ser interessante você recorrer a um financiamento.
Lá na aula da calculadora do leilão, a
gente falou que se você comprar a compra
de um único imóvel à vista ou parcelado,
obviamente o lucro da compra à vista será
maior, já que você não vai pagar juros
como ocorre em uma compra financiada.
Agora, a gente também falou que existe a
possibilidade de você comprar um imóvel à vista
e com esse mesmo capital dessa compra à
vista, você conseguir diversificar em mais imóveis utilizando
o financiamento.
E aí se você somar o lucro total
da venda que você vai ter com esses
imóveis a mais que você diversificou, somando esses
lucros, provavelmente você vai ter um lucro maior
do que na compra de um único imóvel
à vista.
Você compraria um único imóvel à vista com
o capital e com esse mesmo capital você
conseguiria comprar mais imóveis se você diversificasse optando
por um financiamento em leilão ex-credencial.
Então isso é algo que você deve pensar
ali, é algo que você deve fazer na
sua própria análise do que você tem como
objetivo nos leilões e sim decidir por financiar
um imóvel para diversificar o seu patrimônio ou
optar por um financiamento para que você comece
a praticar o seu conhecimento que você vai
adquirir aqui no final do curso nos leilões
de imóveis.
Quando a gente fala de comprar um imóvel
financiado, surge uma dúvida muito comum.
E essa dúvida é a seguinte, é possível
vender o imóvel que está financiado?
E a resposta é sim, não existe nenhum
impedimento para você vender esse imóvel que tem
um financiamento.
Só que você precisa saber de algumas coisas,
de como é que acontece a venda desse
imóvel financiado.
Quando a gente fala de um financiamento então,
da compra de um imóvel financiado em um
leilão, a gente está falando, por óbvio, que
o tempo vai ser um grande aliado do
arrematante.
Porque afinal de contas, quanto mais rápido você
vender esse imóvel, menos juros você vai pagar
e maior será o seu lucro.
Você vai tirar pouco dinheiro do bolso, vai
conseguir vender o imóvel ali por um valor
próximo ao valor de mercado ou exatamente pelo
valor de mercado, ou se você quiser acelerar
um pouco essa venda.
Uma das estratégias que você pode usar é
aplicar um desconto ali no valor que o
mercado geralmente cobra por um imóvel similar ao
seu.
A gente vai estudar isso melhor lá no
módulo 4.
Mas assim, você pode comprar com desconto e
vender pelo valor de mercado.
E aí, no financiamento, você vai tirar muito
menos dinheiro do seu bolso do que em
uma compra à vista.
Então você precisa saber sempre isso, que o
tempo é seu aliado, porque você vai pagar
menos juros e por pagar menos juros, maior
será o seu lucro.
Como de fato funciona a venda desse imóvel
que está financiado?
Para a venda do imóvel que está financiado,
existe a figura do interveniente quitante.
E essa figura pode ser utilizada quando o
comprador quiser comprar o imóvel à vista, ou
seja, você arrematou um imóvel em leilão utilizando
um financiamento, na hora que você for vender,
a pessoa que quiser comprar o seu imóvel,
ela quer comprar o seu imóvel à vista.
Esse é o primeiro cenário.
E existe o segundo cenário, que é o
comprador querendo comprar o seu imóvel, mas ele
também quer utilizar um financiamento.
Vamos estudar, então, como é que funciona em
cada um desses cenários.
O primeiro cenário é o comprador querendo comprar
o seu imóvel à vista.
Quando a gente arremata um imóvel em um
leilão extrajudicial utilizando um financiamento, vai existir uma
nova alienação fiduciária nesse imóvel.
E essa nova alienação fiduciária vai ter como
devedor fiduciante o arrematante e como credor fiduciário
o banco que levou aquele imóvel a leilão.
Então, vai existir, da mesma forma como a
gente sempre estuda nos leilões extrajudiciais, as duas
figuras de sempre, credor e devedor, sendo o
credor o banco que levou o imóvel a
leilão e sendo o devedor o arrematante que
optou por comprar o imóvel com financiamento.
Então, vai ter esse financiamento e esse financiamento
também precisa ter uma garantia.
Afinal de contas, o banco, quando empresta um
dinheiro para alguém comprar um imóvel, ele precisa
de uma garantia que ele vai receber aquele
valor de volta e essa garantia vai ser
novamente uma alienação fiduciária com a transferência da
propriedade do devedor, que no nosso caso aqui
vai ser o arrematante, para o credor, que
vai ser o banco que levou aquele imóvel
a leilão.
Então, quando você for vender esse imóvel, essa
alienação fiduciária vai precisar ser cancelada para que
ocorra a transferência da propriedade do imóvel do
arrematante para o comprador.
Para a gente cancelar essa alienação fiduciária, tem
que existir o pagamento daquela dívida em aberto,
ou seja, o saldo do devedor daquele financiamento
tem que ser pago para que ocorra o
cancelamento da alienação fiduciária e, aí sim, a
transferência da propriedade do arrematante para o novo
comprador.
Como é que você vai fazer isso em
uma compra à vista?
Quando a gente vende um imóvel, é muito
normal que a gente faça uma promessa de
compra e venda.
E essa promessa de compra e venda tem
uma finalidade principal, que é a seguinte, estipular
um pagamento de uma entrada para aquele imóvel
e, aí, garantir que o vendedor quer, de
fato, vender o imóvel pelo aquele preço que
for acordado para determinado comprador e garantir que
o comprador vai comprar aquele imóvel daquele vendedor.
E, aí, o comprador paga esse sinal para
que o negócio fique, então, amarrado.
Ambas as partes garantindo que vão fechar aquele
negócio.
Isso é muito normal no mercado imobiliário.
É a forma mais comum da gente vender
um imóvel.
A gente faz esse contrato, estipula o sinal
e, aí, depois, sim, a gente passa para
a fase de escritura de compra e venda.
Por que existe, também, esse contrato?
Por que a gente, geralmente, não pula direto
para a escritura de compra e venda?
Porque, quando você vende um imóvel, você precisa
de um tempo para levantar umas certidões que
vão passar segurança para o comprador.
Que certidões são essas?
Em primeiro lugar, a certidão mais absoluta que
tem sempre, que envolve a compra e venda
de um imóvel, que também é muito importante
para a gente em leilão e que a
gente já estudou, que é a matrícula do
imóvel.
Você precisa apresentar aquela matrícula atualizada, demonstrando que
não tem nenhum ônus recaindo sobre aquele imóvel,
uma penhora, uma indisponibilidade, coisas desse tipo.
A gente vai estudar todos esses termos bem
a fundo no módulo 3, já que esses
termos, geralmente, a gente encontra em leilão judicial.
Então, não precisa se adiantar um pouco.
Aqui é só, realmente, uma pincelada de por
que existe esse contrato, essa promessa de compra
e venda.
Então, estipula esse sinal, garante que as partes
estão vinculadas naquele negócio e aí você tem
um tempinho para levantar as certidões necessárias e
depois, sim, finalizar a compra e venda com
a escritura e depois o registro da escritura
na matrícula do imóvel, transferindo, de fato, a
propriedade para o comprador.
Então, quando a gente tem um imóvel financiado
e o comprador quer comprar à vista, a
gente vai ter que pagar, quitar esse saldo
do financiamento.
Só que aí o atual proprietário, que no
nosso caso aqui é quem arrematou o imóvel,
ele não precisa ter esse dinheiro para quitar
esse saldo devedor, porque, afinal de contas, se
ele precisasse ter esse dinheiro, ele compraria o
imóvel à vista, ele não precisaria recorrer a
uma compra financiada.
Então, como é que vai funcionar esse pagamento
desse saldo devedor?
O comprador e o vendedor vão fazer ali
uma promessa de compra e venda, estipulando um
sinal e esse sinal deve ser o suficiente
para quitar esse financiamento que está em aberto.
Então é feita ali essa promessa de compra
e venda, o comprador vai pagar esse sinal,
o vendedor vai receber esse sinal, vai até
o banco que ele tem o financiamento, vai
falar, olha, eu quero quitar esse financiamento agora,
o dinheiro está aqui, do saldo devedor, o
banco vai receber esse pagamento, vai emitir ali
um termo de quitação e esse termo de
quitação, o proprietário, que é o arrematante, vai
levar o cartório de registro de imóveis para
dar baixa nessa alienação fiduciária.
A partir do momento que o proprietário der
baixa na alienação fiduciária, proprietário e novo comprador
podem comparecer a um cartório para realizar ali
a escritura de compra e venda e depois
registrar o imóvel no nome do novo comprador.
Então qual vai ser o lucro?
O comprador vai pagar um sinal suficiente para
quitar o financiamento, o vendedor, que é o
arrematante, vai chegar lá com esse sinal, vai
pagar aquele valor para o banco para liberar
a alienação fiduciária.
E o restante da compra, a diferença entre
valor de venda e valor necessário para quitar
o saldo devedor é o lucro e o
comprador vai pagar esse lucro diretamente para o
vendedor.
Então o vendedor vai lucrar dessa forma.
Lembrando que você sempre deve fazer análise do
máximo que você pode oferecer do 11, da
sua viabilidade financeira, recorrendo à calculadora do leilão
que está disponível lá na aula 11.
É só voltar para assistir à aula e
também entender melhor como você pode lucrar porque
a própria calculadora do leilão, na aba de
financiamento, ela te apresenta o lucro que você
vai ter com essa compra financiada.
A segunda forma de você vender é se
o comprador quiser comprar o seu imóvel também
recorrendo ao financiamento.
E aqui vale o mesmo, para que entre
esse financiamento desse comprador, que nada mais vai
ser do que um registro de uma alienação
fiduciária na matrícula, afinal de contas o banco
vai emprestar o dinheiro para esse comprador, ele
vai querer uma garantia de que esse comprador
vai pagar aquele valor que ele está recebendo
de financiamento através da constituição de uma alienação
fiduciária com a transferência da propriedade do comprador
para esse banco que o comprador escolheu.
Então, para que exista o registro dessa nova
alienação fiduciária na matrícula do imóvel, vai ter
que existir o cancelamento da alienação fiduciária que
existe entre arrematante e banco que levou o
imóvel ao leilão.
E aí vai funcionar de duas formas dependendo
de como o comprador quiser comprar aquele imóvel.
Se o comprador quiser optar por um financiamento
com o mesmo banco que o arrematante tem
o financiamento, o próprio banco vai aprovar o
financiamento do comprador, vai liberar o dinheiro para
quitar ali o saldo devedor do vendedor, dando
baixa na alienação fiduciária, depois registrando essa nova
alienação fiduciária para o comprador, e aí entregando
a diferença de valor da venda menos valor
do saldo devedor para o vendedor que vai
ser o arrematante.
Então é assim que o vendedor vai lucrar,
porque afinal de contas o valor da venda
vai ser maior do que o valor suficiente
para quitar o saldo devedor, e aí a
diferença dessa conta é o lucro que o
banco vai entregar diretamente ao vendedor.
Então o próprio banco ele faz essa conversa
ali interna falando que tem uma pessoa que
quer comprar um imóvel, que ele tem um
financiamento com o vendedor, ele vai quitar o
financiamento do vendedor, registrar o novo financiamento desse
comprador, e aí liberar a diferença na mão
do vendedor que vai lucrar com essa operação.
A segunda hipótese seria o comprador recorrendo a
um financiamento num banco diferente do que o
vendedor, que é o arrematante, tem o financiamento
dele.
E aí nesse caso também os bancos vão
conversar entre si.
Então vamos supor que o comprador ele quer
recorrer a um financiamento com o Bradesco, e
o vendedor que é o arrematante ele participou
de um leilão feito pelo Itaú, e tem
o financiamento dele lá com o Itaú.
Então seria o Santander conversando com o Itaú.
O Santander vai aprovar o financiamento desse novo
comprador, e aí quando o comprador ele fala
para o banco que ele quer comprar um
imóvel à vista, o banco vai pedir lá
a documentação do comprador e também do imóvel.
Quando o banco analisar aquela documentação do imóvel
ele vai ver, olha tem uma alienação fiduciária
aqui.
Então ele vai conversar com o Itaú para
saber qual é o valor do saldo devedor
daquele financiamento que está garantido por aquela alienação
fiduciária que está constando na macrícula daquele imóvel.
O Itaú vai informar qual é o saldo
devedor, o Bradesco então vai liberar esse valor
do financiamento para quitar o saldo devedor para
o próprio Itaú, vai existir a baixa na
alienação fiduciária, vai ser registrada a nova alienação
fiduciária com o banco que o comprador escolheu,
e o banco do comprador vai liberar também
a diferença entre o valor da venda menos
o valor suficiente para quitar o saldo devedor
para o vendedor que também irá lucrar com
aquela venda.
Essas operações acontecem literalmente todos os dias, várias
vezes ao dia no mercado imobiliário.
Então para quem nunca teve contato com esse
tipo de promoção pode parecer ali algo pouco
complexo um banco conversando com outro para quitar
o saldo devedor e depois liberar a diferença
na mão do vendedor.
Só que isso não é nem um pouco
complexo, os bancos fazem isso aí várias vezes
ao dia, é algo realmente muito viável, é
algo realmente muito possível e algo que pode
ser muito interessante para que você participe dos
leilões de imóveis.
Afinal de contas você pode optar lá para
um financiamento em um leilão desprejudicial e vender
esse imóvel logo após a desocupação do imóvel,
após a regularização da documentação do imóvel, e
aí sim lucrar bastante com essa operação.
Lembre sempre de fazer previamente, antes de oferecer
qualquer lança no leilão, a análise da sua
viabilidade financeira com a calculadora que está disponível
no módulo 1 e aí sim você já
tem uma noção de quanto você pode lucrar
com aquele negócio.
E lembre sempre que numa compra financiada o
tempo é seu grande aliado.
Quanto mais rápido você vender, mais rápido você
vai lucrar e maior vai ser o seu
lucro pela menor incidência de juros que você
vai pagar.